so one of the I think most common
questions I hear young people at
ambitious young people ask is I want to
be the next Elon Musk how do I do that
um obviously the next Elon Musk will
work on very different things then than
you did but what have you done or what
did you do when you were younger that
you think sort of set you up to have a
big impact well I think this one should
say that I do not expect to be involved
in all these things so the the the five
things that I thought about the time in
in college quite a long time ago 25
years ago you know being you know making
life multiplanetary selling lowering the
transition to sustainable energy the the
internet broadly speaking and and then
genetics and AI I think I didn't expect
to be involved in in in all of those
things I actually at the time in college
I sort of thought helping with
electrification a bit of cars which was
how we start out and that's a that's
actually what I worked on as an intern
was advanced ultra capacitors with to
see think there would be a breakthrough
relative to batteries for energy storage
and cars and then when I came out to go
to Stanford that's what I was going to
be doing my grad studies on is it was
working on her best at energy storage
technologies for electric cars and I put
that on hold to start an Internet
company hit in 95 because
that does seem to be like a time for
particular technologies when they're at
a steep point in the inflection code and
and I didn't want to you know do PhD at
Stanford and then and what sure will
happen and then and I wasn't entirely
certain that the technology I'd be
working on would actually succeed I can
get you can get a you know doctrine or
many things that ultimately are not do
not have a practical bearing on the
world and I wanted to you know just I
really was just trying to be useful
that's the optimization it's like what
are what can I do that would actually be
useful
you